Вітаю вас шановні пані та панове ми всі
сьогодні Зустрічаємося на дуже цікавій
події яка фактично завершує цілу низку
вебінарів очних подій зустрічі круглих
столів які відбулися в рамках
всеукраїнського тижня професійної освіти
і європейського
а Шановні колеги ввімкніть будь ласка
мікрофони та європейського року навичок
в Україні
сьогоднішня подія вебінар навички для
стійкості та відбудови як ми можемо
передбачити потреби в навичках
підготовлені міжнародного організацією
праці та міністерством освіти і науки
України
ми сьогодні з вами зустрічаємося для
того щоб дослідити різні шляхи
передбачення потреб у навичках і
професіях які є необхідними як у
поточній ситуації в якій ми з вами
знаходимося так само і
вони будуть потрібні в майбутньому для
відбудови України на основі перевірених
інструментів які існують наприклад
використовуються міжнародною
організацією праці і будемо наводити
конкретні Приклади того що вже
відбувається в цій царині в Україні Я
думаю що всіх хто сьогодні приєднався
будуть згодні з тим що саме в нашій
країні дуже актуальним є зараз
передбачення потреб в тих навичках які
потрібні як вже підготовленому
професійна активному населенню так і для
молоді
ми тут сьогодні запросили
представників
різних міністерств відомств а також
експертів які відповідають запитання
освіти зайнятості соціального захисту і
питання відбудови нашої країни
представників організації роботодавців
професійних спілок і Авжеж в закладів
професійного освіти
освітніх закладів
навчально-методичних центрів професійної
освіти Департамент освіти і науки інших
партнерських організацій і партнерів з
розвитку Міністерства освіти науки
України серед спікерів У нас сьогодні
будуть пані Ірина шумит генеральна
директорка директора та професійного
освіти пані Олександра мольц яка
представляє офіс міжнародної організації
праці у Центральній та Східній Європі
пані
балор-амурчук яка представляє напрям
навичок саме у міжнародній організації
праці пані Лариса лісогорець спиртка з
питань ранку праці
пан Геннадій русанов який є заступником
директора польського фонду солідарності
програма її фоскілс краще навички для
сучасної України Мене звати Тетяна
Білецька я заступниця директорки з
напрямок професійної освіти команди
підтримки реформ Міністерства освіти і
науки я буду вашою модераторкою і нам
допомагають свої колеги з команди
підтримки реформ експерти Олексій Ситник
та пані Наталія Проценко
ви нас зможете дивитися або на YouTube
каналі Міністерство освіти і наука а
також брати участь приєднавшись до зону
всі з вас зможуть взяти участь в
опитуванні моменти метру коли ми з вами
поширимо ці потрібні технічні
налаштування щоб ви могли взяти участь в
цьому опитуванні Отже ми з вами
Починаємо працювати і плідної роботи я
маю надію нам Побажаю своєму вступному
слові пані Ірина шумів пані Ірина слово
вам
Вітаю Тетяно Добрий день шановні колеги
знаєте надзвичайно приємно коли ти
долучаєшся до ефіру прямо з полів Я
зараз перебуваю в академії патрульної
поліції і ми завершуємо сьогодні семінар
на якому навчали викладачів закладів
професійної освіти до медичній
підготовці можливо буде дивним і
незрозумілим чому саме до медичній
підготовці і саме викладачі протеху але
Варто сказати що на вимогу часу ми
сьогодні розуміємо Наскільки важливим є
безпека всіх учасників процесу учнів
викладачів наскільки важливо стала
навичка
уміти надавати допомогу і
все ж таки готувати наших здобувачів
освіти і викладачів до того що можуть
бути ситуації небезпеки я дійсно Дякую
всім хто доєднувався до нас Протягом
цього всього тижня я точно знаю що це ще
не завершення ми працюємо над тим щоб
весь рік європейський рік навичок
пройшов надзвичайно успішно в Україні
але зараз хочу подякувати нашим
партнерам
з міжнародної організації праці От
бачите в мене тут трошки шумно бо
академія живе і завершилися заняття
зараз
міжнародна організації праці власне пані
олександрів Яка із задоволенням
відгукнулася на нашу пропозицію і
допомогла організувати цей вебінар
сьогодні ми будемо говорити про світові
практики і про практики з міжнародної
організації праці в частині
відповідності навичок чому ми почали
говорити про навички а не про дипломи Та
не про документи не про освіту в цілому
тому що сьогодні
документ без практичних вмінь він нікому
не потрібен і ми як система освіти якраз
маємо бути нецілені на здобуття нашими
здобувачами освіти практичних навичок
які є актуальними і затребуваними тільки
в такому випадку і ми і наші випускники
будуть успішними тільки в такому випадку
ми можемо гарантувати що економіка
України
відповідного розвитку і нам вдасться
успішно відбудувати нашу країну І от
власне для ефективної правильної чи то
можливо мене Геннадій сьогодні виправить
Smart від будови України нам треба мати
в нашому арсеналі відповідні інструменти
щоб відповідати вимогам часу тому
Шановні колеги я з радістю бачу всіх і я
розумію що на годиннику вже 15:40 і для
п'ятниці мати таку кількість учасників
на вебінарі це
надзвичайне диво я дякую вам за інтерес
і бачу роботодавців пані Людмилу пані
Валентину з проекту Дякую що не
залишайте вийдужими і дякую родіони за
попередній вебінар теж Боже я ми вже
всіх знаю і Бажаю всім гарної плідності
праці
Дякуємо за такі теплі слова пані Ірино
маємо надію що ми дійсно дуже плідно
попрацюємо зараз я збираюся передати
слово пані але сам дрімольц яка проведе
інтерактивне опитування з використанням
інструменту ми з вами спробуємо
подивитися що ми знаємо про передбачення
навичок які є в цій сфері міфи А щоб ви
розібралися як ми будемо працювати Я
зараз вам поясню технічну сторону
у чат боксі нашого зуму ті хто працює в
Зумі ви можете побачити одне посилання і
лінк це на питання першої і другої коли
ви зайдете ви зможете надати відповідь а
потім другий лінк ви зможете зайти
надати відповідь на питання три і чотири
так само на екрані ви побачите
qr-код для перших двох
і потім пізніше для питання 3 і 4 як
варіант Як вам зручніше ви зможете або
відсканувати qr-коди прямо з телефону
зайти або ввести в свій пошуковий
браузер ментіком ввести Той код або
клікнути на лінк і зайти з комп'ютера Як
вам буде зручніше а тому пані Наталія ми
можемо запускати перші два питання в
інтернеті пані але самбро передаю слово
вам для того щоб провести це наше
інтерактивне опитування
Тетяна Вітаю всіх багато є відомих і
невідомих облич я вітаю Ірину що Микита
тягнув Білецького і всіх представників
мон
Дякую за організацію такого заходу Так
це п'ятниця вже надвечір і завжди не
просто щось зробити в цей час давайте
підвищуємо рівень активності перше
питання в меті метри таке
[музика]
Чи маєте ви досвід щодо прогнозування
потреба навичка
там є невеличке коло зображене воно
рухається в мультиметру
І багато хто відповідає що немає такого
досвіду
у більшості є якісь досвід
передбачування потребу навичках
Зараз ми зводимо остаточні відповіді вже
вчать його можете натиснути на посилання
і перейдете до ментиметра
там ви побачите відповідні питання
тому приходьте за посиланням Вибирайте
відповідь яка відображає ваш досвід щодо
передбачування потреб по навичках або є
або нема або трохи
або є якісь конкретний досвід практичний
в цьому вибираєте підхожий варіанти
відповідаєте
Я думаю через qr-код або посилання всім
вдалося перейти можна через телефон це
зробити
в цифровому віці Ми всі знаємо навіщо як
qr-коди
в принципі тенденція вже вимальовується
Отже в нас є приблизно половина людей
серед учасників в яких є певний досвід
хочу загальні знання про те як
передбачувати потребу навички це вже
непогано і є також велика група людей в
яких немає такого досвіду прогнозування
Я думаю це вебінар допоможе вам
розібратися краще з цим надати якісь вам
знання розуміння питання
ті хто не має досвіду Я думаю в принципі
він якийсь є щодо передбачування навичок
Просто ви його так не формулювали для
себе але протягом єдинарової напевно
зрозумієте що ми щось таке робили
конкретування проводили співбесіди
вивчали інформацію про ринок праці не
без того
так більше в нас тут не рухається
картинка Ну начебто всі питання всі
відповіді вірніше надійшли давайте
переходити до наступного питання
там також передбачають різні варіанти
відповіді
Так ми готові перейти до другого питання
і демонструвати друге питання так так
так сейчас я хвилинку Добре дякую
бувають несподіванки Начебто все гаразд
коли потрібно на все спрацьовує на
діоксліт
Росії
це ще по Першому питанню в нас
друге питання
полягає в тому які призначення такого
передбачування потреби в навичках Навіщо
це Що з цим робити
в нас декілька тут є варіантів відповіді
і вентилятор скорого з'явиться на
екранах Я думаю І ми побачимо
що в нас там з відповідями
Сподіваюся всім вдається Зайти туди і
надати відповідь
людям хто дивиться наш наш на YouTube
каналі що ви теж бачили qr-код і коли
бачите слайд qr-кодом можете брати
участь так само як і наші колеги у Зумі
будь ласка
в нас з'являється відповіді на друге
запитання
передбачувані потреби навичках для чого
це все
варіант а для аналізу того скільки
випускників
з відповідною кваліфікації увійдуть на
ринок праці в наступні три роки друге
для опрацювання синергії щодо
майбутнього попиту на робітників по
конкретних професіях
третя для розрахування точного числа
робітників які потрібно в майбутньому по
специфічних конкретних видах професій і
далі для розуміння тих змін які
впливають на ринок праці і це дегаткова
про те як її кваліфікації навички
потрібні від робітників в тих чи інших
професіях Ну в принципі тенденція
зрозуміла
і тут я знов-таки різні варіанти
відповідей але здебільшого ми бачимо
вибрали варіант б
варіант тоді
вони є вірними тобто в принципі все
згодиться тобто таке прогнозування
допомагає розібратися з тим скільки
людей з'явиться на ринку праці тут
йдеться про попит
про те скільки буде робочий сили ми
будемо розуміти які навички я не
підходжу ми до вимог також за допомогою
працювати сценарії особливо якщо ми
використовуємо прогнозні методології
разом зі статистичними викладками
з минулих років І це дає нам краще
розуміння
того що буде в майбутньому я також це
допомагає зрозуміти зміну ринку праці ми
говоримо про ключові чинники змін в
цьому сенсі
далі обрахування точна кількості
робітників яка буде потрібна от все ці
підходи вживалися в минулому
і
межа Ніколи ми не отримали вірну
відповідь тому що навряд чи можна
визначити
конкретне число кількість Ну може в
короткостроковій перспективі це можливо
але віддалений перспективі на майбутнє
це важливо важко зробити тому що багато
змін здійснюється це ускладнює ситуацію
є і технологічні зміни і інші зміни і
Вони змінюють повністю становище
ми знаємо як воно було наша пандемія яка
рідна і Отже варіант AB та ді вони всі
вірні
це все входить в процес передбачування
потреби в навичках
проходимо до питання номер три знову
повертаємося до чату натискаємо на
посилання по третьому питанню
А я вже бачу я навіть результати дуже
гарно
просто Чудо якесь
тут є питання з невеличким підвохом тим
не менше думаю ви його зрозуміло воно
таке якщо ви хотіли дізнатися про те
який професії та навички будуть потрібні
в майбутньому то вам були потрібні дані
щодо майбутнього
і тут є можливий варіант так потрібні
дані б не потрібні дані варіант - це
попит та пропозиція на ринку вирішують
проблему
тому що так дані потрібні для того щоб
подавати прогнози і розуміти тенденції
ми потрібні мати статистичні викладки
тобто якісний і кількісні дані аби
аналізувати технологічні зрушення
але важливий зібрати дані щодо
майбутнього в нас нема
кристального шарика навіть з його
допомогою Навряд чи ми роздивилися все
майбутнє тобто дані про майбутнє зібрати
не можна тим не менше можна
використовувати дані на сьогодення і з
минулих років щоб розуміти і
прогнозувати і аналізувати тенденції
про попит пропозицію на ринку вирішують
проблему є такий варіант я тут можу
сказати так що в сфері
профтехосвіти ми завжди
відстоюємо від
того що відбувається Якщо ми будемо
чекати поки Ринок сам розбереться з
проблемою
то ми будемо запізнюватись тому що
інвестиції в простого світу великі і
освіти в село Ми також є
ми маємо зрозуміти куди все рухається
хтось каже дані не потрібні також
цікавий варіант відповіді до речі якщо
визначати дані як статистичний викладки
суто То може й так тому що ми можемо
зібрати статистику про майбутнє однак ми
можемо отримати якийсь факти і
якісної оцінки від спеціалістів які
працюють по галузях щоб розуміти що буде
потрібно то Ми дякуємо вам за надання
відповіді тепер переходимо до наступного
питання
щодо передбачування потреби в навичках
є посилання на нього
тут як райдуга прямо в нас вже є різні
види відповідей Хто мав забезпечувати
прогнозування потреба навичках про в тих
заклади ВУЗи компанії організація
роботодавців бізнес-об'єднання
профспілки
до цього відповіді
профспілки недооцінювати тому що вони
також знають тільки навички будуть
потрібні навіть ніж краще це знають ніж
начальство компанії
я бачу трохи додали варіант Тут
профспілки відповідей
МОН України
державна служба працевлаштування
державного статистична служба Ну все
відповіді в принципі вірні можна навіть
сказати так що немає єдиної відповіді
тут спільна відповідь сполучення
відповідей є вірним
та разом так копи і ми потім з вами
побачимо для чого це все
система передбачування навичок
Мерс задати це в комплексі
Отже ми трохи провели таку інтерактивну
вправу Дуже дякую вам за активну участь
тепер переходимо до вступу до теми
передбачування навичок
[музика]
Так зараз ми приберемо менти метр
Олександра зараз розкаже нам більше про
підходи міжнародної організації праці до
аналізу і передбачення потрібних в
майбутньому і актуальна потрібних
навичок Крім того ми почуємо певне вступ
до такої цікавої методики такого
цікавого інструменту як SD більше зараз
вам все розкаже пані Александра будь
ласка пані Олександра слова вам
Тетяна
чому
так ми переходимо до
виступу про принципи передбачувані
навичок і
хоче представити тут два знаряддя
ми обрали цю тему тому що
в принципі ви знаєте як Дарвін казав що
ми самі сильніший виживають і
нерозумніші А на ті виживають Хто
найкраще адаптується до змін
тому і проводиться передбачувані навичок
і тому я б навіть сказала так що це
важлива річ також для вашої країни і
зараз для того щоб ставати стійкішої
української економіка має продовжувати
працювати
навіть за проточних умов війни
Ну і також знадобиться до реконструкції
важливо от розуміти які навички потрібні
і
цікава стаття макензи
який йдеться про те
наскільки українська економіка зараз
проявляє велику стійкість і
це велика та невелике таке питання
в поточному стані продовжує працювати
економіки ммами підтримати всіх тих
людей які ми Зате работує забезпечити
собі проживання отут ми бачимо що
необхідно проводити передбачувані
навичок навіть в середині ситуації
стосовно підходів мов мопси між народною
організацією праці це агенція ООН в
питаннях праці яка резиде різні теми які
дотичні до
працевлаштування світу праці
цей сприяння працевлаштування зайнятості
це охоплює навички і про втек навчання
соціальний захист робітників
трудові права на робочому місці
соціальний Діалог Діалог між
роботодавцем і та їх організаціями і
профспілками і урядом Ми віримо в те що
такий тристоронній діалог може здобувати
найкраще здобутки для всіх для
працівників для молоді для підприємства
для економіки для соціального розвитку
[музика]
тут ви бачите ті країни які ми охоплюємо
Якщо говорити про передбачення навичок
то
виникає питання про те чи ми готуємо
молодь
підхожую перспективні професії якщо
разом технологічні політичні Кліматичні
зміни ті які стосуються охорони здоров'я
ми не знаємо як вони є Коли ми готуємо
молодь для майбутнього працевлаштування
ми навчаємось одному але щось інше
потрібно буде в майбутньому
технологію може змінитися проблеми
будуть інші
зараз під час війни одне становище і Тут
виникає важливе таке питання для країни
навичок то слід думати про ринок
там є пропозиція
працівників з певними навичками які
підходять або може не підходять під
попит на самі цей навички серед
підприємств
це подбати про те що по молоді були
відповідні навички і у дорослих також
які потрібні підприємством щоб
підприємство змогли знайти собі людей з
підхожими навичками
якщо це баланс
не здійснюється то тоді є не
співставлення між навичками Та ринками
це може оформлятися по-різному тут ви
бачите перелік
категорії такої
невідповідності навичок
є випускники або працівники які вже
працевлаштовані яким не вистачає навичок
на виконання певних робіт ефективним
чином і вони слід Їм слід пройти
перепідготовка або до навчання
бо нема навичок скажімо
певні навички вже відпали тому що були
технологічні зміни походу
не вистачає людей з підхожими навичками
на донавчання робітники
не відповідають тому що вимагається на
роботі по кар'єрі буває на відповідність
Тому можливо що молодь обирала таку
кар'єру яка
відповідала як прагненням не також щоб
там були для них можливостями ринку
праці в цьому інодіє на співставність по
сферах навчання
тоді це марно втрачена Інвестиції на
навчання тому що людей вчила днів
професії а потрібно щось інше
переклад
по різних країнах світу ми бачимо що
багато випускників навіть вузів які їм
не просто знайти роботу і є люди з проте
кваліфікацією які такого страждають від
цього але й та інше можуть бути
перспективи перспективним кар'єрним
вибором
прогнозування навичок - це не точно
наука Ми не можемо зібрати дані про
майбутнє як я казала Ми не можемо чітко
побачити як вона буде в майбутньому але
ми можемо цільовим чином розглянути
тенденції на ринку із опрацювати певні
сценарії
корзинами очинники змін Ось вони якщо
їсть - це технологічні інновації
організація праці та процес не дорівнює
підприємств глобалізація демографія
зміна клімату і рівень освіти
політичні проблеми та ситуації від
перетворення як війна Наприклад Це також
чинник змін
причому саме важливе зараз у вас в плані
економіки і в плані адаптації до всього
цього
до ситуації з війною і як я казала
Ви дуже гарно себе проявляєте в цьому і
дякуючи технологіям які є в нас є
можливість проводити от свої вебінар
наприклад
щодо передбачування навичок слід
розуміти чого ми шукаємо
Чи це визначення конкретних професій щоб
зрозуміти скільки працівників фахівців
інженерів
буде потрібно
зростання попиту на них або занепад
попитом на відповідні
працівники також які навички будуть там
потребуватися в цих професіях
здебільшого в принципі те і одне інше і
тому дуже не просто навіть дуже складно
передбачувати потреби в навичках і до
того що слід розуміти
кого Ми розглядаємо молодь
яка
3-4 роки вже вчиться на того щоб
опанувати певну професію чим розглядаємо
роботи людей яким потрібно
пройти при підготовку або ми розведемо
безробітних тому що виходячи з цього ми
краще зрозуміємо скільки за часом це все
займає
і кожна група
потребує інших от громадських підходів
ми маємо зібрати це з тим як людей
пустити на три підготовку зараз надаючи
короткі курси ми говоримо про дорослих
або може про випускників ПТУ які перший
рік працювали десь
Я коли вони завершили навчання то висить
подивитися чи їм знадобилося повні
повній мірі ті навички які вони там
набули навчання на робочому місці
постійно адаптація і підвищення навичок
це так дослід брати до уваги і це
дозволяє нам розглядати використання
різних інструментів та метод саме
процеси і тут ми бачимо посередині
що секрет полягає у успішному поєднанні
всього цього слід використовувати якісні
та кількісні методики для цього підхожі
якщо ви тільки покладаєтеся скажімо на
прогнозування по навичках або на
статистику
розглядаєте те
що там було з минулого і на цьому
грунтуєте прогнози майбутнього то це дає
вам невірно картину слід туди додати
іншу інформацію наприклад якісно
додати по фокус групах розмову з
фахівцями
з роботодавцями
анкетування їх слід також розуміти ці
гроші які є для
Проведення таких вивчень і елементів ми
побачили що це має бути спільне зусилля
всі мають відігравати тут свою роль і
зрештою
передбачування навичок
розглядається як пиріг Причому на
будь-який пиріг
А такий слойоний є там різний прожарки
от є мікроривень є ПТУ пам'ятати в
питаннях ментів Metro там був місцевий
рівень
і в компаніях городавці проводять
передбачувані навичок щоб зрозуміти
хто їм потрібен і ПТУ працюють з
підприємствами напряму подекуди для того
щоб розуміти краще що потрібно на
місцевому рівні на підприємствах можна
дивитися на
галузевий регіональний зріз галузевий -
це вправках конкретних галузі А я також
макрори рівень і на всіх цих рівнях
можна використовувати
кількісні і якісні види даних
статистикою не тільки для того щоб
розуміти чим ми дивимося на
найближче майбутнє
середня перспектива або віддалену
перспективи там 15 років та більше і
така система передбачування має
охоплювати всі ці прошарки і всі ці
структури і заклади які там працюють
я отакий графічек де ми бачимо
короткострокової стрік до одного року
середньостроковий до 5 до 5 років від
довгостроковий до 15 років і там різні
рівні і відповідно різні методики можна
там використовувати
хочемо представити вам зараз цей
методології Але перед тим що слід
поговорити про співставлення навичок як
відповідати тому що очікується на етапі
навчання і освіти
з одного боку йдеться про створення
стандартів професійних та
кваліфікаційних які які оновлюється час
від часу розробляється навчальні
програми і готуються викладачі але я
також планування в галузі освіти
проводиться професійна орієнтація молоді
включаючи їх батьків
активні програми проводяться на ринку
праці все це вписується в програмі
активного залучення до ринку праці
є методології які опрацьовувалося в Моп
Я не про все буду говорити тому що в нас
на це все нема часу про інше
разом
є помаранчеві настанови як ми це
називаємо це добірка методології які ми
опрацьовували разом з Європейським
фондом підготовки ітф
структура також яка працює в сфері
профтехосвіти
[музика]
Також ми проводимо обстеження
підприємств роздаємо сценарії прогнози і
також є
матеріали які перекладені на українську
мову Я хотіла український варіант
вивести із забола Ну і потім дам
посилання Сьогодні ми хочемо представити
методики Мот
одна з них допомагає розібратись з тим
що відбувається на рівні галузі тобто що
там блакитне позначено так ось також
проводяться онлайн і курси підготовки
коли ви отримаєте цей матеріал ви
зможете по цих посиланнях вийти на
відповідне добірки інформації навіть
залучитись до курсу підготовки
які проводить наш центр підготовки в МОП
тепер ми розглянемо
про ті знаряддя Які в нас є
це навички для підготовки економічної
диверсифікації Я дуже радий що з нами як
Олега баларна та Марчук і вона
брала безпосередньо участь у розробці
цього ну не тільки вона але вона була
одним з провідних фахівців яка була
залучена до форматування методики стенд
вони проводили на Філіппінах це на
практиці ну це галузева методика
А є що методика яка була під ковід
заточена ми зараз я ататуємо під
контекст вашої країни
це експрес-оцінка попри навчання та де
навчання Тобто це щось робиться в
експрес-режимі що дозволяє швидко
зрозуміти
які потреби зараз на ринку праці в
навичках що підприємства краще розуміли
що потрібно
по навичках
щоб державна служба зайнята і знала які
програми при підготовці налаштувати як
підшукати людей з підхожими
компетенціями які можуть пройти швидко
при підготовку і адаптувати з-під
компетенції які потрібні зараз але вже
це оперативна така оцінка оперативне
знаряддя і
це дуже корисно для кризових ситуацій
коли змінюються швидко ситуація
Лариса ліса город згодом виступить
розповість Яка робота проводиться по
адаптуванню цього до контексту вашої
країни
Я не хочу щоб це було чимось абстрактним
тут є така ідея
Якщо у вас є підхожі навички
що може зміцнити можливості підприємств
в конкретних галузях встиглих які
зростають Які важливі для економіки
країни то такий підприємства підвищує
продуктивність і конкурентноспроможність
в них будуть рости продажі і буде
економічний розвиток і будуть
створюватись кращі робочі місця в цій
галузі їх буде більше
галузевий рівень
це може бути галузь де країна проводить
торговлю з кимось або можуть бути
вітчизняні галузі і тут є варіанти для
диверсифікації урізмитнення і то
залучається різні зацікавлені сторони
які об'єднуються разом по галузі і сам
процес який тут передбачений він такий
що проводиться аналіз проводиться
початкове вивчення щоб зрозуміти попит
пропозицію в галузі і чи є цей баланс
між ними в плані навичок
далі проводиться
семінар з питань прогнозування і через
два тижні в Сербії по готельному сектору
планується там провести таке вивчення
таке семінар далі формується стратегія
де розставляється пріоритети от над цим
не розбираються розставляють пріоритети
по
більш важливих заходах які слід провести
обидві підвищити кількість людей в яких
Я підходжу навички щоб дати їм Стимул на
набуття таких навичок
а я думаю передам слово Оболоні і
вона розповість що це методологія Естет
може нам дати
Тетяна повертає вам слово
Дякую вам за те що нам коротенько
розпели то не менше це дає нам гарне
розуміння і підходів і знаряддя які
можна використовувати для оцінки навичок
тепер
в форматі інтерв'ю ми дізнаємося про це
трохи більше
з панією
Клок яка якраз займається питаннями
оцінки навичок в міжнародній організації
праці тоді Запрошуємо пані болор і перше
питання полягає Ось у чому ми б хотіли
вас запитати пані малума чому Міжнародна
організація праці розробила методологію
для
прогнозування потреб у навичках саме на
галузевому рівні які переваги дає
розгляд потребу навичках на галузевому
рівні
Я радий приєднатися до цікавого заходу
разом з колегами своїми
щодо вашого питання що мова вирішили
саме галузевим шляхом піти всі методи
[музика]
як Олександр казала Ми зараз живемо в
світі де
тільки зміна є постійною величиною
тому є структурні зміни і розвиток
навичок як напрям стає важливим
Якщо говорити про
інклюзивний характер цих структурних
змін
підходжу навички система яка дозволяє
сформувати це важливі підмурки не тільки
для
того щоб скористатися з тих можливостей
які йдуть структурні зміни але це також
дозволяє країнам
проявляти більшого стільки здох
потрясінь та змін
напрям по навичках в правдихосвіті
навіть
як правило
недооцінюються Коли уряд планує щось
підструктурні зміни
намір то вірний доволі часто
вони визнають важливість навичок У
рамках політики освіти але при цьому все
ж таки вони не доходять до рівня
деталізації для того щоб зрозуміти
конкретні навички та проблеми які є в
тій чи іншій галузі щоб віднайти підхоже
рішення
з іншого боку
підприємства в одній галузі як правило
використовують потрібні навички і вони
беруть на роботу людей які володіють
подібними технологіями тобто тут не
тільки підприємство є Але є різні
організації роботодавців
кафедри дослідницьких інститутів
освітні заклади регулятивні структури
вони всі як правило мають
галузеве спрямованість цієї тому в нас є
певна добірка зацікавлених сторін які
якщо будуть працювати разом то зможе
скласти стратегію визначити навички
потрібні для майбутнього успіху тому у
2010-муп опрацювали от Цей підхід який
називається
степ навички задля економічної
диверсифікації і це практичний напрям
доволі гнучкий як Олександр казала який
можна адаптувати під певнувалось і Він
дозволяє грузитися на перспективи щоб
допомогти країні і управлінцям працювати
разом
з працівниками представниками
певних галузей щоб зрозуміти стратегічні
потреби галузі задля успіху в
майбутньому наче президенти які будуть
потрібні навички і кому
а далі разова не зможуть працювати
спільне бачення цього і визначитись
потребами навичках чого не вистачає які
я проблеми і разом зможуть скласти
конкретний план дій
я багато знаряддя передбачування навичок
древньої галузей умов але задача та
полягає в тому що вийти на комплексний
варіант опрацювання навичок і вписати це
в план розвитку конкретних галузі
включається
змогу я повинна вести всеукраїнською
повертаюся до українського Ми б хотіли
якщо можна Трошки краще зрозуміти як
саме
стенд методологія працює в чому полягає
процес оцінювання за методологією
процес складається із чотирьох складових
початкова фаза далі діагностична фаза
потім фазреалізації і визначення
спроможностей відповідних структур
урядових структур
на початковій фазі
ми збираємо разом зацікавлених сторін
щоб визначити із ключовими галузями на
яких слід зробити основний нахил
після цього
разом сама зацікавленими сторонами
переходимо на етап діагностики і там
в нас є
два види процесу в залежності від
того що вони виберуть
я повноцінний стенд є експрес-варіант
методологія або оперативний
і вибір процесу такого або варіанту
залежить від того скільки в нас час часу
в розпорядженні скільки ресурсів є
і скільки є інформація даних
може нам слід зібрати первинні дані про
навички
шляхом проведення вивчення навичок
повний обсяг методології ST
він займає більше часу а оперативний
варіант - це займає менше часу і це
вивчення проводиться в режимі
прогнозування проводиться семінарство чи
ми зацікавленими сторонами за два дні
Все готово от фаза діагностики дозволяє
підготувати цей практичний семінар а
далі є фази реалізації де вже вживається
всі ці рекомендації які були
напрацьовані на етапі діагностики
я от хочу ще повернутися до етапи
діагностики
на тому етап і все зацікавлене сторони
підключаються і методика поєднання двох
моментів є стратегічний аналіз який
спирається на Докази і соціальний діалог
це не просто діагностичне вивчення яке
проводить якийсь консультант з колегами
це процес який
залучає всі зацікавлені сторони
вислуховують їх думки І це збагачує цей
спільний аналіз Ну а на прогнозних
семінарах ми разом з зацікавленими
сторонами ми розмірковуємо над тим
можливостями проблемами які в галузі і
опрацьовуємо спільне бачення Ну а потім
бачимо що це означає в плані навичок чи
навички слід підтягнути що нам заважає
які є системні виклики галузі
як ми разом можемо працювати певні
рішення для реалізації замисленого
ну таке
В мене є ще пару питань Але я бачу що
одна з учасниць нашої сьогоднішньої
події підняла руку і я думаю що вона
просить уточнити щось якраз стосовно
останнього моменту тому я даю слово
зараз пані Світлані бацюковій Вона може
поставити своє питання до пані воловна
Дякую Рада вас дуже бачити знову Ми
стаття не вже разом працюємо на перший
раз
питання стосується
того про що я казала Тетяна
ми як Світовий банк думаємо про те що
буде важливе для країни в плані
опрацювання нових компетенцій навичок
професії
я виступаю з боку донорів що і
розглядаються відповідні стратегії та
стимули для того щоб
дати Україні те що їй потрібно те що
буде її важливо для розвитку ринку
макроекономіки
те що я почула про методику стет
можна зрозуміти Я думаю на рівні як
прикладів не обов'язково по Україні
можна взяти інші країни де ви вживали
цей стенд
і це було більш зрозуміло
пані того щоб Ми зрозуміли як це
спрацьовує тому що Для нас це нове і
мене що Давно мали зустріч з іншим
департаментом світового банку і нам там
сказали що вони привела аналіз про
певних ринках і з'ясували що
люди
можуть навчатися
якщо їм ще на 35 тим кому за 35 їх ваше
навчати а щодо набуття навичок та
професійних здібностей Ми чуємо тут
різні думки іноді
є аналітика та звіти з яких ми бачимо що
скажімо в Україні потрібно все ж таки
там будівники або інші кажуть
що айтішники будуть потрібні здебільшого
ну тенденцію змінюється по ходу
але знов таки передачу До свого питання
от можу ви нам змогли б надати пару
конкретних прикладів з країн де методика
стояла вжита
і пояснить нам її на прикладах
А так в мене От напрошувалася те ж саме
питання Я хотіла спитати оскільки разів
ви вже
вживали цю методику
І що є найбільш цікаве що ми могли для
себе взяти з конкретних прикладів
Дякую за дуже влучне запитання щоб бути
конкретною може сказати що в 2010-му цей
метод було представлена і ми вже в 30
країнах
60 голосах це проводили в різних галузях
причому
візьмемо Що було з останнього не
Філіппінах
буквально місяць тому я працювала там з
колегами
по двох галузях
У мене тільки галузі але й території
на Філіппінах є один регіонів там де є
велике будівництво А на півдні країни є
інші регіон бар називається там є
банківські структурно це автономне таке
округ масло мандана називається
Отже Там ми
на сектори риболовства робили нахил і на
сільському господарстві щодо навичок
Ну якщо не брати конкретну територію 100
Все тоді тільки поверхнево можна
побачити які потрібні навички цифрові
комп'ютерні або будівництво Але слід
занурити до підроби з конкретної галузі
що там як Та ну якщо я береться галас це
важливий перший крок А так що взяти
приклад риболовства і сільського
господарства в регіонібаром на філіппіна
як ми намагалися запросити на семінар
підхожих представників проводиться
аналіз ситуації аналіз вихідної ситуації
до цього не можна це як відправна точка
щоб зібрати усі дані
результати по існуючому становичу Ми не
хочемо дублювати чиїсь інший вивчення Ми
беремо все що є якщо не вистачає
проводимо своє вивчення потім на своєму
мерчику за два дні розглядаємо майбутнє
перспективи в галузі з представниками
галузі що всі однаково розуміли що це
які є можливості перешкоди і все оце Ну
тоді зібралися в нас 60 осіб
з інвестиційних банків з регіону з
урядових структур
з міністерства працевлаштування з
міністерства сільськогосподарчої
політики і також були представники
за місцевих громад спільнот сел селищ
тому що це один з самих занедбаних
регіонів країни та маловато можливостей
і маловато робочих місць і можливостей
їх створення
об'єднали всіх цих учасників 4 групи для
проведення сетаційного аналізу
То хто що ми займатися риба кокоси і
інші види продукції ну все-таки під
галузі вже і
розглядали от конкретно по підгалузях
які проблеми і які можливості
і разом вони працювали спільне бачення
на наступні два-три роки можна навіть не
5 річку хтось замахнувся
на основі того що вони знають про
можливості та проблеми і коли в них є
такі спільне бачення майбутнього Вони
працюють разом
якийсь і розуміють які навички йдуть
потрібні для того щоб вийти на це
омріяне майбутнє ще вони можуть що не
можуть зробити разом Що слід зміцнити
покращити в конкретному виді підгалузей
і там вони визначають які навички йому
потрібні хто цим буде займатися якщо
взяти риболовство то рибного
господарство щодо цього потрібно яке
сьогодні професії там є чи в нас є
проблема з навичками робітників що
обмежує
Може я навички вищого рівня я навички
рівня профтих освіти або навіть нижче
Вони все це розкладають по поле цих і
розуміють над чим працювати який там є
потреби в навичках і хто має про це
подбати
І от на цьому рівні також визначається
вже конкретні навички 5 чи інші професії
в одне з часом з цим обговорюється
системні обмеження в плані пропозиції
розглядають над якими питаннями слід
попрацювати щоб все пішло Гаразд в
галузях бо навіть під галузі
це все робиться спільними зусиллями
зацікавлених сторін
далі формується платформи де ці сторони
збираються раз відразу і обговорюють все
в деталях усіх підробицях
його опрацьовують спільні рішення
В неї є або питання або комент думаю
дуже
Тетяна
хочу показати один слайд по семінару
який ми проводили пастет
Я не знаю ви бачите слайд чи ні
в мене кудись подівся PowerPoint
розшукують не можу знайти
Так зараз може з'явитися
я от пробую його вивести
але зледку десь подівся серйозно
Я спробую пізніше просто хочу сказати що
ми розглядали
по сектора it в Боснія і Герцеговини
потреби в навичках Я маю визначилися із
професіями які дотичні до it і вони
найбільш потрібні
[музика]
конкретні там напрями але
потрібні які розуміють
кого під час літної мати в конкретному
секторі або галузі і Якщо говорити про
навички тому що можемо пограти про те
які будуть потреби в навичках на
майбутнє
себе в онлайн семінар про ковідні
ситуації винесли близько 50 рекомендацій
і
60 підприємства за участь вони
розставляли проратити Потому що вони
хотіли провести для того щоб ці навички
люди здобули
були злочені компанії до цього семінара
вона там висловлювалися говорили що їм
потрібно
можна провести тренінг по наданню
конкретних навичок можна
підвищити рівень кваліфікації по таких
та професіях але іноді це відноситься до
внесення змін до постанов для того щоб
люди навчалися без відриву від
виробництва тоді компанія Вам легше
підготувати молодь прямо на виробництві
замість того щоб відряджати їх на якісь
курси кудись
також можуть бути інші варіанти заходів
які будуть прописані в постановах в
офіційної політики в тому як працюють
навчання заклади Ми ще не знаємо які
будуть результати цього процесу стать
Цікаво буде побачити що це дасть Але
хотіла надати це приклад щоб ви розуміли
що це може бути за процеси що він зможе
дати
ми з вами розглядали цю методологію
приблизно зрозуміли як вона працює якісь
конкретні приклади для країни і навіть
для різних секторів але я б хотіла ще
раз попросити якщо можна коротко
підсумувати В чому є результати тобто що
саме дається методологія І заодно Я б
хотіла приєднати два коменти або питання
від публіки скажемо так тому що ось наші
слухачі кажуть що Вони думають що ця
методологія може бути корисна для
підготовки галузевих рамок кваліфікації
наприклад або вона ще може
використовуватись для стартапів Тобто ми
б хотіли від міжнародної організації
праці почути чи дійсно в таких умовах
вона б могла працювати для
цих цілей будь ласка пані балонову
Александр
Дякую за те що ви додали
до будівничого сектору філіппінус кажу
так от в одній стороні вони побачили що
там повільно проводилися адаптація нових
технологій і з цим були проблеми
зацікавлені сторони зібралися поговорили
про результату вони кажуть що ми
працювали інформацію по такій та галузі
в такому та регіоні там тепер знаємо як
Яким шляхом рухатись там скажімо 50%
всього семінару були представники
компанії великих малих різних
а ті ж знають на місцях які проблеми
вони це сказали всім решта учасникам і
урядовим представникам і навчальним
закладом
далі вони розглядають які основні
технології які є в країні які
а яких не мав
іноді не вистачає кваліфікованих кадрів
для того щоб ті технології там
запроваджувати
можна підвищити рівень поінформованості
про ці технології і
багато різних сертифікація атестації але
вони нестандартизовані і через це
виникають проблеми
серед службовими закладами які там кожен
надає якісь
курси підготовки і от вони стикнулися
системою проблемами я не моглася
розібратися в тому по результату що було
ну зрештою
вони побачили що тут є великий рівень
залучення Багато залежить від співпраці
тобто слід залучати підхожих
представників і
все це робиться під Рудою галузі Хоча і
представники різних Міністерства але
лідерство проявляє саме галузь і навіть
на рівні галузі
все це має бути дотичним до Національної
стратегії розвитку тому що звідти будуть
надходити інвестиції якщо є проблеми з
навичками ми прив'язуємо це до
Національної стратегія розвитку через
відповідні Міністерства ще одне
це дозволяє розставити пріоритети від
образити найближче перспективи для
партнерських структур
Побачити які проблеми з навичками яких
не вистачає які з них є на більш
важливими які варіанти обладнання цієї
ситуації
от вони разом працюють над вирішенням
цих питань
тут головне - це спільна робота Ну і
зрештою
це призвели до оформлення стратегії по
навичках яка все відображає Ну і далі
виходить ця співпраця на новий рівень
тут можна сказати от про приклад рибного
господарства там на семінари вони вже
сформували
партнерство по між собою
з місцевими мешканцями вони вказали що
нам тут потрібні люди робітники
серед тутешніх і
регіональних банк приєднався а працювали
концепцію
рекомендації і потім намагалися їх
втілити
Тобто Це сприяє таке партнерським заявам
Походу того як роздивляється це тематика
навичок
події є ще одна фінальне запитання ви
нам розповіли про те як працює стенд
методика ми ще будемо чути про методику
швидкого оцінювання і не могли б нам
пояснити чим вони відрізняються одна від
одної
і опис перейшов тут дуже легко це
пояснити
Ми хочемо передбачити навичок
разом зацікавленими сторонами зробити
так щоб люди їх отримали тут ми
суміщаємо різні методи
залучені від певних сторін тут принцип
під це те скільки часу на це потрібно
експрес-варіунд або оперативний варіант
при навчання буде навчання Це питання
часу швидкості ми маємо швидко при
підготувати або навчити людей є
можливості на рівні підприємств на рівні
економіки в плані відбудови відновлення
І от і підприємство ранішевих ринках
Вони мають ці можливості їм потрібні
люди вже сьогодні з відповідними
навичками але вони не можуть їх
відшукати тому таке оперативне до
навчання або про навчання і буде більш
підхожий варіант вони побачать хто є в
кого як і навички є якого до навчити або
принавчити тобто все це просто в часі
який потрібен на повну мето більше часу
потрібно на оперативний варіант менше ну
і залежить також від специфіки галузі
зрозуміти як застосовуються Ці дві
метадології А зараз я хочу сказати
учасникам сьогоднішньої події що ми
дізналися про наявні інструменти з якими
працюю міжнародна організація праці і
тепер ми сфокусуємось на тому що є
найбільш цікавим для нас як для
професіоналів з України ми подивимось як
ці методології швидке оцінювання і
методологія Естет можуть працювати в
контексті українському слово ми надаємо
пані Ларисі Лісогор яка є експерткою з
питань ринків праці і вона нам
представить це питання і також покаже
свою презентацію продемонструє пані
Ларису Запрошуємо вас до слова
Дякую
Шановні колеги дуже рада всіх вас бачити
Бажаю всім вам саме головне
мирного неба
здоров'я щастя і всього найкращого щоб в
нас все було добре Ну якщо ви не
заперечуєте я Буду намагатися якомога
швидше не займаючи багато часу
розповісти описати ті
методологічні підходи які були цікавими
і корисними для нас тому що дійсно ми
розуміємо що те що казала має Олександра
для нас дуже важлива не тільки зрозуміти
що відбувається на ринку праці яким
чином змінюється навички але не
зрозуміти яким чином реагувати на це ми
знаємо що зараз в нас
в Україні Україна характеризується тим
що навіть незважаючи на нашу ситуацію в
якій знаходиться країна дуже багато
ініціатив
ініціатив присвячених якраз дослідженню
проблем проблем пов'язаних з навичками
проблем пов'язані з професійною
складовою робочої сили і ми розуміємо що
ті виклики які стоять перед нами в
умовах Обмеження
можливостей статистичного обліку
відновлення даних статистичних я
статистичного аналізу в зв'язку з
військовою ситуацією ми розуміємо що
зараз якісні
методи дослідження ринку праці і змін
навичок індивітів дуже важливо для нас
дуже актуальність тож можете Я зараз
перейду до найбільш таких цікавих
речей які були у для нас корисні і для
України загалом це проблема в тому що що
означає
Експрес оце оперативне оцінювання потреб
у перенавчанні і покращенні навичок з
урахуванням впливу війни та саме головне
в контексті повоєнної реконструкції та
відновлення ми розуміємо що Міжнародна
організація праці якраз ставиться на
пріоритетні позиції не тільки
забезпечення те що казала
Олександра не тільки забезпечення
економічних диверсифікації не тільки
забезпечення розвитку підвищення
конкурентом спроможності національних
економік але загалом на перше місце
ставиться якраз проблема якості робочої
сили гідної праці забезпечення
можливостей гідної праці соціальної
інклюзії і забезпечення стійкості щоб
для нас дуже важлива в наших умовах і
яким чином досягати цих цілей це
насамперед ті методологічні підходи до
ідентифікації існуючих та нових потреб у
навичках для прискорення структурних
змін як власне секторальному рівні в
період повоєнного відновлення Не менш
важливим також є формування пропозиції і
переліку практичних заходів стосовно
забезпечення перенавчання і покращення
навичок для їх збалансування з потребами
праці якраз теж у контексті
реконструкції та відмови якщо ми
подивимося на цілі реалізації процесу
екстрасенню то для нас дуже важливим є
такі три аспекти насамперед це
ідентифікація теж існуючих і нових
потреб навичка тому що ми розуміємо що в
нас зараз відбувається якраз злом і
структурні зміни пов'язані з тим що
виникають нові навички Нам необхідно
реагувати швидко реагувати реактивно на
те що відбувається зараз для нас дуже
важливим є ідентифікація пріоритетних
сфер як впровадження цих закладів
заходів і напрямків реалізації що це
означає насамперед це означає що нам
необхідно визначити ті сектори економіки
які можуть бути драйверами ми пізніше я
просто розкажу більш детально про це але
це теж дуже важливо і звичайно це
визначення подальших дій щодо реалізації
заходів тими інституціями які якраз і
залучені і забезпечують перенавчання і
покращення навичок протягом періоду
реконструкції по воєнного відновлення
цільові сфери це специфіка особливість
якраз цього інструменту який
пропонується тобто визначення тих
секторів в яких війна найбільш негативна
вплинула на зайнятість Не менш важливим
є визначення цих секторів цих професій
які реконструкції повоєнне відновлення
може стимулювати збільшення потреб в
темних навичках і створювати можливості
зайнятості праців
Ників а також третя цільова сфера - це
групи осіб індивідуалів які потребують
перенавчання навчання і покращення мови
Якщо ми будемо розглядати методологічні
підходи то вони загалом відповідають тим
загальновизнаним підходом який
застосовується до усіх досліджень які
проводяться в ціні визначення і
визначення перспектив змін навичок Це
кабінет на дослідження Тобто це аналіз
як зазвичай статистичних даних але ми
розуміємо що в наших умовах ми будемо
спиратися на ті дані які є тобто ті дані
які є відкритому доступі а також
опитувань Дослідження які проводяться в
багатьма експертними групами в нашій
країні
це обстеження підприємств на предмет
визначення того який навички були
затребувані які були найбільш потрібні в
період війни
напередодні і які можуть змінитися цей
набір навичок в майбутньому
а також опитування індивідуальні групи
осіб тобто працівники
безробітних які теж входять до складу
економічно активного населення а також
проведення консультації поглиблених
інтерв'ю з основними зацікавленими
сторонами з цих добривами ось тут дійсно
тут дуже важливо якраз налагодженість
створення цієї мережі
зацікавлені кисів які будуть не тільки
експертаминій настільки ми вже бачимо що
в нас в Україні якраз і формується дуже
такий потужний ви знаєте потужна мережа
тих хто зацікавлених хто є експертами і
хто дійсно проявляє зацікавленість Тобто
це дуже можливо для нас для нашої країни
і це перспективність може привести до
дуже позитивних результатів якраз в
нашій країні які інструменти обстеження
і опитування і тут дуже важливі питання
ми потім будемо відповідати на них
будемо дискутувати Але яка форма
опитування тобто які інструментарії може
використовуватись ми знаємо що є у вас
кінці які мають досить цікавий досвід
проведені
опитування роботодавців за сприянням
Федерації роботодавців за активну участь
і допомоги державної служби зайнятості
використовували якраз онлайн онлайн
платформ Для нас це дуже важливим
розуміємо що
Експрес оцінювання яке було
запропоноване на основі якого
розроблялася наша основа запропонований
розроблений міжнародною організацією
праці воно стосувалося якраз викликів
які постали перед країнами у контексті
ковід ковід-19 Тобто це використання
онлайн-інструментів для України Це дуже
актуальна тому що ми розуміємо що Для
нас це це це можливості які відкривають
якраз доступ до інформаційних технологій
коли в наших умовах необхідність
забезпечення особистої безпеки це дуже
серйозне питання також хто буде
обслуговувати цю платформу підтримувати
відповідальний інституція це теж дуже
важлива питання Ну і Часовий горизонт ми
розуміємо це те що дуже-дуже важливе
питання
ми розуміємо що це
ті етапи основні складові основні стадії
експрес-аптілювання які якраз ми вже
проаналізували раніше але дуже цікавим
це є Останнє не тільки проведення
консультацій з найбільш відповідальними
основами в полі сімейкерами які
приймаються але зведення оцих
оперативних Експресо ціна і підготовка
звіту а також валідація результатів
звіту тобто для нас дуже важливо не
тільки зробити узагальнення отриманих
результатів але спілкуватися з цей
колдорами із залучати їх до того щоб
вони реагували якраз безпосереднім чином
і оцінювали це потрібно чи ні причому це
стосується якраз не тільки стенд тобто
стенд він зорієнтований насамперед на
сектори економіки для нас дуже важливим
є також регіональний аспект тому що ми
розуміємо що дуже багато секторів які
по-різному починали втрати і зазнали
проблем з розвитком які були наприклад
металургія яка експортно-орієнтована яка
буде бюджетна формується це стосується
сільського господарства ми знаємо тих
викликів тих проблем якійсь якими
стикнулися ці сфери економіки але ми
розуміємо що вони все одно є драйверами
але він ще питання є регіон який більше
постраждали від впливу військових дій і
в них сконцентровані якраз ці сектори
бюджетно формуються експертна
орієнтований яким чином нам на це
реагувати тобто для нас дуже важлива
вислухати точку зору і думку якраз всіх
хто буде приймати в цьому участь
обстеження підприємстві любить секторів
насамперед це стосується зміни
показників економічної діяльності
підприємств зайнятості вакансії тобто
той алгоритм який і приймався для
проведення обстежень однак тут дуже
ва якраз
визначити ті
параметри і ті показники які Які
найбільш важливі для майбутнього періоду
реконструкції і воєнного скільки ми
розуміємо що зараз Нам необхідно
реагувати дуже швидко на те що
відбувається що стосується опитування
індивідуальних цільових груп то це зміни
статусу зайнятості професії набору
навичок потреб визначення потреб
підготовці просто підготовці
використання цих результатів для
проконсультування
для того щоб вносити вже відповідні
зміни ті куліку акти навчальні програми
в цій освітній програмі які вже
пропонуються і дуже важливо тут є аспект
такий як робота
найбільш важливими вестами населення
Тобто це внутрішні переміщенні особи це
ветерани війни Тобто це демобілізовано
Тобто це проблема соціальної політики
Тобто це не тільки забезпечення
стійкості секторів перспективі за
рахунок того що будуть мобілізовані
ресурси
буде підготовлена робоча сила з
відповідними навиками але й це
можливості соціального залучення і
уникнення наростання якісь тамплідні
ситуації в майбутньому це дуже важливо
для нас тобто соціальна згуртованість і
соціальна залучення управління процесами
це теж дуже важливий важливий аспект і
тут між міністерська взаємодія Тобто ми
розуміємо що якраз Нам необхідно
координація в питаннях оцінювання і
розроблення заходів щодо ефективного
реагування на нові потреби на швидкі
зміни потреб це Конституція консультації
з інституціями провайдерами освіти та
навчання з організації ми роботодавців і
просивками це теж дуже важливо тому що
для нас ми розуміємо що соціальний
діалог дуже важливий цих питаннях і
відповідними публічними приватними
співходорами це експертне середовище -
це недержавні організації і
розуміємо що керівний комітет який може
бути створений за участю ключових
технологій це теж потрібно обговорювати
теж треба дискутувати з цих питань хто
це тебе мав бути Міністерство освіти
науки у місті та економіки національна
агенція кваліфікації тобто тут дуже
важливо оце симбіоз і мені такоєднання у
цих усіх зацікавлених
[музика]
зацікавлених сторін усіх сторін ходерів
ключових стрільбирів Із залученням е-е
громадянського суспільства із залученням
Особливо дуже важлива ніж органами
місцевого самоврядування тому що в
умовах децентралізації для України це
дуже важливо і ми розуміємо що дуже
важливим є залучення провідних
Міністерства агенції важлива дуже
важлива Роль державної служби зайнятості
із директоратом професійної освіти які
виступають знаєте як драйверами тих
дослідження аналізу який відбувається
Останнім часом в Україні
потреба секретаря технічна команда це
буде обговорюватися але це загально
визнано пріоритет Якщо ми будемо
дивитися на основній стадії якраз
узагальнення результатів Експреса
оцінювання то дуже важливо Ми теж весь
час спілкуючись цей колдрами будемо мову
про те що нам необхідні конкретні
рекомендації вже пройшов в той час коли
ми можемо проводити аналіз і робити
висновки але висновки не перетворюються
практичні конкретні рекомендації на
даному випадку необхідно мабуть робити
такі знаєте як такі узагальнення які
може потім трансформуватися в розмер
карту дорожньої карти тобто що необхідно
робити для всіх це не тільки
ідентифікація заходів політики це
стратегія секторального розвитку це
стратегії регіонального розвитку які
дуже важливі для досягнення найбільш
важливих результатів забезпечення
зайнятості
це ми розуміємо що під впливом війни і
повоєнне відновлення якраз відбувається
якраз зміни оцього набору навичок і вони
повинні ця зміна повинна відстежуватись
якраз на основі результатів опитування
консультацій поглиблених інтерв'ю а
також розробка варіантів безпосередніх
конкретних рекомендацій і варіантів
реагування швидкого реагування з боку
системи освіти
очікувані результати ну це насамперед
дійсно це анонтований виклад презентації
основних висновків якраз з урахуванням
сфокусований на можливих варіантах
розвитку подій або конкретних
рекомендацій з детальним допоміжним
аналізом тобто що треба робити для того
щоб або мінімізувати негативні наслідки
або для того щоб зробити
швидке швидко зреагувати і змінити той
набір навичок потрібно для цього сектору
або просто аналіз ситуації перспективи
розвитку цільових секторів також Це
розробка комплексної дії для
забезпечення ефективної діяльності у
розвитку навичок в кожному цільовому
секторі або кожній окремі генотип і
рекомендації варіанти діток ми
зосереджуємо увагу якраз на конкретну
претемоцію які переваги і які бенефіти
дах впровадження цих рекомендацій у
насамперед ми розуміємо що є різні е-е
різні цей холдери і підприємства
провайдери освіти професійного навчання
індивідуальні групи осіб
служба зайнятості і органи місцевого
самоврядування органів місцевої органів
влади ми розуміємо що тут для
підприємств ми
увагу на тому що якраз тут
інструментарій яким чином взаємодіяти з
системою освіти для того щоб може за
допомогою дуальну форму світу
забезпечувати підготовку використання
кваліфікаційних центрів для
підтвердження
кваліфікації отриманих неформальних
шляхів Тобто це різні інструментарій але
підприємства будуть розуміти що є
координація і є реагування системи
освіти швидке на вимоги ринку праці і ми
бачимо що зараз у нас система освіти
система професійної освіти достатньо
внучка вже реагує ми вже бачимо ті
позитивні приклади які йдуть Тобто це
стосується інформування це стосується
соціальної реклами тобто йде взаємодія
між суспільством
розмовами між відкрита розмова між
суспільством між роботодавцем
для провайдерів оскільки професійного
навчання ми розуміємо що це робота з
оновлення навчальних планів
освітніх програм тобто у рік Вибачте
будь ласка я вимушена на секунду вас
перервати Ні не в цьому Справа у нас
технічна проблема У нас чомусь вимкнувся
перекладач я не можу зрозуміти його не
чують Зараз ми розберемося пане Сергію
можете ввімкнути свій мікрофон а то я
мені не вдається вас Анною А на якому
моменті це сталося ну це нещодавно
сталася але мікрофон перемкнувся нам
треба його ввімкнути Вибачте я не знаю
це якась технічна похибка буває буває
все на украинском канале
де
English speaking
problem We have to On You
Thunder happened
так вже чують все гаразд
все гаразд вже чують
Так можете продовжувати в нас все гаразд
Так можете продовжувати все в нас
налагодилося
спрямування тобто що
професійна орієнтація і консультування
тобто ці результати також дуже важливі
оскільки для нас ми розуміємо що дуже
важливо розуміти тим хто виходить на
ринок праці Де найбільш затребувані в
будь-якій навички яким чином Їх потрібно
служба зайнятості ми розуміємо що це
сегмент зареєстровано на ринку праці
дуже важливий якраз в цих умовах тому що
ми розуміємо що проблема якраз з
безробіттям вони достатньо самотні вони
наростають тому для нас дуже важлива
якраз теж оновлення навчальних планів
програми наближення її до практичного
змісту перепідготовки безробітних якраз
на основі інформації про швидке
реагування Ну і для органів місцевої
влади тут було в чаті дуже цікаве
запитання стосовно того що
яким чином ця методика співвідноситься
смарт-індефікацією
[музика]
ідентифікацію навиків для потреб смак
спеціалізації якраз от тут дійсно є
перетинання є деякі речі які дуже багато
мають схожого але ми розуміємо що в
даному випадку якраз тут основний
основна специфіка якраз оцієї методики
Експрес да реагування Експресу цінювання
це швидке реагування тобто якщо смарт
спеціалізація регіону вона потребує
якогось проміжку часу тому що ми
розуміємо що необхідно
задіяти всі ресурси для того щоб
забезпечити подальшому розвиток смак
спеціалізації То якраз тут необхідна
якась реагування для того щоб
мінімізувати ті ризики які виникають
якраз в період повоєнного відновлення
інколи навіть давати допомогу тим
секторам текст на що ми звертали увагу
раніше Які найбільш постраждали вони
якраз не відноситься до смак спеціаліза
але вони потребують цього реагування
тому що це може привести до соціального
виключення і якраз органи місцевого
влади місцева самоврядування якраз і
розробленість стратегії регіонального
стратегії розвитку громад і стратегії
розвитку регіонів якраз на основі смарт
спеціалізації з використанням свого та
аналізу але ми розуміємо що те що вони
були прийняті розроблені зараз вже
відбувся повний злом того що відбулося
тобто необхідно переадресація визначення
інших пріоритетів і реагування якраз на
регіональному рівні на рівні громадської
це дуже важливо в умовах децентралізації
якщо ви не заперечуєте як
яким чином нам можливо аніціювати да оце
експерт Експрес оцінювання Це дійсно
інформування інформування ключових
технологій щодо можливостей ознайомлення
із методикою і цілі основні етапи
створення мережі підтримка вже існуючої
мережі Якраз для того щоб залучати все
більше учасників зацікавлених здійсненні
проведення консультацій дуже важлива це
проведення консультації з ключовими
стей-хунтерами щодо вибору сектора або
регіонах базуючись якраз на основі цих
критеріях і обговорення методологічних
підходів Тобто це вже питання які будуть
відноситися до організації
але для нас дуже важливо якраз
зосередити увагу і сформувати той у ту
мережу найбільш зацікавлених осіб які
будуть
не тільки зацікавлені але які зможуть
давати експертні пропозиції щодо того на
що треба звернути увагу тому що якщо ми
подивимося на
стегнатодології це вже те що розповідала
і Олександра і балорма але в контексті
якраз відновлення що може бути цікавими
для нас тобто вибір секторів якраз
звертаємо увагу на те що вибір сектору
або регіонів з урахуванням якраз з
текстомтерієм та наслідків впливу війни
Тобто ми розуміємо що на це треба
звертати увагу і вести дискусію з
постановкою
визначення бізнес спроможності сектору
зі значним потенціалом для зростання І
тут якраз за рахунок стратегічного
підбору навичок необхідних для
забезпечення відповідності якраз цих
навичок потребах сектора підтримка
реалокованих підприємств це дуже важливо
для ідентифікації набору найбільш
необхідних навичок Тобто це теж
залучення елемент залучення соціального
залучення можливості навчання
трьохпідготовки і зайнятості осіб в
цільовому секторі і тут дуже важливо
якраз зосередження уваги на
забезпеченні розвитку навичок і
адаптації найбільш важливих беруть
населення тому що визначити той набір
навичок Який необхідний для даного
сектору для даних професій саме навичок
і як розробити програми для того щоб їх
швидко перевчати і адаптувати Тобто це
дуже серйозне питання
ось якщо ви не заперечуєте останнє це
критерії критерії якраз визначення
сектору які пропонуються в методикою
аспект Тобто ми розуміємо що ті критерії
які зараз
запропоновані це критерії Мирного часу
тобто вони для нас були розроблялися
Стебні методології і вона була
застосована в умовах Мирного часу то
звичайно це дуже важливо потенціал
експертної експертного Зростання
економічної диверсифікації чи мається
цей сектор перспективи економічного
розвитку інтенсифікація навичок тобто
наскільки її навички будуть сприяти
розвитку сектору наскільки вони
динамічні потенціал створення робочих
місць Але й гідно і зайнятості це теж
дуже важливо і пошук синергії це
уникнення дублювання з іншими
стратегіями розвитку тобто якщо
секторальної іде розвиток на основі це
то щоб не було дублювання з іншими
стратегіями які вже допомагають цьому
секторі Тобто це це
надлишкове використання ресурсів
відповідальність за проведення тобто
залученість партнерів це дуже важливо і
наскрізні пріоритети це
наскільки наскільки сектор може
інвестувати в навички для покращення
якості робочих місць секторів it-сектор
наприклад він інвестує в розвиток
достатньо активної ми розуміємо що зараз
наша держава в смартфоні її місцевої
трансформації
Міністерство роблять дуже багато для
цього але не не всі сектори економіки
зараз мають можливості для інвестування
тобто для чого потрібна їм допомога тому
в нас дуже важливим в цьому контексті ми
можемо використовувати ці критерії для
відбору сектору але дуже важлива це
критерії потреб відновлення Тобто ми
розуміємо що те що може стати той сектор
економі які може стати драйвером
перспективі наскільки він може слугувати
драйвера і той сектор який може зазнати
дуже значних деформацій але відбулася
знаєте як кажуть структурна структурна
перебудова структурна реформація тобто
те що відбувається інколи дає поштовий
для того щоб оновлювати модернізувати
тобто і для цього потрібно якась
визначення пріоритетів з боку держави і
з боку регіону з боку громади тобто
поєднання цих усіх трьох рівнів
за активної участі усіх роботодавців
представників
профспілок представників
інституцій це дуже важлива якраз тут
створення цього Тулу Ну і питання для
обговорення ми вже сконцентрували увагу
на цих питаннях ми розуміємо що це вже
може бути потім тема нашого обговорення
але для нас дуже цікаво є якраз те що
зараз можемо використовувати цей
інструмент який був вже розроблений і
якраз зараз він адаптується до умов
наших Тобто це повоєнне наше виклики
якісь постали перед Україною внаслідок
війни і повоєнного відновлення тому що
нам вже зараз необхідно думати про це
тому що ми розуміємо що економіка
повинна відновлюватися а це означає що
стимулювання створення гідної зайнятості
і робочих місць Тому що тільки Це може
допомогти подолати ті кризові серйозні
кризові явища які вони Коли у нас в
економіці і наростають на ринку праці ми
розуміємо що у нас є демографічні
проблеми дуже серйозної демографічний
розрив ми розуміємо що в нас є дуже
велика вітті економічні активного
населення і тому в цих умовах якраз
підбір і гарний і збалансований підбір
необхідних навичок і реагування системи
освіти яка вже зараз починає реагувати
на те щоб і розвивати це дуже важливо
Дякую Вибачте за мовою
пані Лариса дуже дякуємо за вашу
доповідь Це дійсно важлива коли ми
бачимо як щось працює в українському
контексті і ми всі зібралися саме для
того щоб зрозуміти що може бути
придатним корисним для нас нам треба
мобілізуватись і швидко реагувати на те
що відбувається зараз більше того ми
повинні розуміти що буде відбуватися
через 3-5 років і готуватися до цього як
мінімум зараз в принципі у нас Мені
здається унікальна пілотна ситуація в
країні багато інших країн потім
в майбутньому зможуть
використати досвід України Я абсолютно
напевно унікальний досвід у нас
відбувається дуже цікавий обмін думками
думками ще і вчать боксі на жаль у нас
не залишиться багато часу на питання
відповіді як ми хотіли тому я дуже прошу
всіх кому цікаво дивитися Час бокс у нас
є є одна доповідь інтервенція Скажімо
так і Може в самому кінці Ми дамо все ж
таки слово ще одному з учасників з дуже
цікавою ініціативою А зараз по програмі
Я б хотіла перейти до дуже цікавої
роботи яка була нещодавно виконана це
дослідження ринку праці в Україні у 2022
році 2023 році яке було зроблено в межах
програми UFO Skills краще навички для
сучасної України Я даю слово зараз пано
Геннадію
росанову який є керівником компоненту
цієї програми з боку
польського фонду солідарності і ми б
хотіли зрозуміти
що вони зрозуміли про деякі
передбачувані і затребувані навички
тобто поговорити про
контекст оцінки ринку пра ці саме в
аспекті питань передбачення навичок в
Україні пане Геннадію слово вам будь
ласка вітання Тетяна Доброго дня всім
колеги менеджер поганий зв'язок я
спробую без камери тому не прошу не
ображатись
дуже мене чути Добре
Алло
чути Добре Це в порядку Ми здебільшого
пам'ятаємо
як гадаєте
Я не знаю чи це плюс але дякую
добрий день колеги дуже приємно бачити
багато знайомих обличчя багато знаємо
людей дуже коротко про те власне той
ініціативи яку ми реалізували вже під
час війни спільно з колегами з
Європейського банку реконструкції
розвитку в рамках програми Skills А так
само з допомогою служби державної служби
зайнятості Федерація роботи України та
Міністерство освіти і науки України
власне
протягом
листопада
2022 і завершуючи в березні 2023 року
тобто
буквально Недавно ми завершилися роботу
ми провели такі великі Вивчення ринку
праці які власне базується в основному
на тих методиках і підходах про які
говорили колеги за міжнародною
організацією Праці а так само на тих
методиках це дефолп який теж про які теж
сьогодні говорили
дослідження мало три компоненти ми
провели аналіз існуючої статистики
очевидно під час війни Вона має дуже
багато проблем ця інформація ці дані Ми
так само провели величезне опитування
роботодавців ми питали 8000 підприємств
зі всіх регіонів очевидно окрім
тимчасового окупованих територій До речі
до нас долучився так само і Херсон який
на той час зробив деокупований за що ми
щиро вдячні тому
і третій компонент це було ні 12
галузевих фокус груп
було озвучено понад 150 експертів з
різних галузей Вони теж діяльність
колегам з цих підприємств які знайшли
можливість думаю нічого
які основні власне висновки з цього
дослідження очевидно там дуже-дуже
багато інформації ми задоволенням
поділимося з колегами детальним звітом
чи навіть власне даними які були частого
дослідження але кілька таких основних
висновків перший - це стосується перше
стосується власне Не самих результатів
вивчення аналізу ну по праці чи тих
потреб які е-е які ми побачили а з самої
системи в Україні про яку трошки
говорила пані Лариса Яка теж До речі
допомагала нам за що теж вдячні е-е
насправді один з таких основних
висновків говорить про те що в Україні
дійсно сформувалися вже така громада чи
спільнота людей які займаються системно
вивченням ринку праці займалось до війни
під час війни
інституцій державних які які це роблять
роблять все краще завдяки тому числі і
підтримці і нашої програми і колекції з
міжнародної організації праці і ця
система виявила як на мене величезну
резистентність до тих проблем викликів
які виникли через війну Тобто ми
насправді були щиро і приємно здивовані
тими результатами тим залученням людей
коли небайдужістю і те що ми в рамках
нашої роботи під час війни
змогли і нам змогли допомогти наші
колеги з регіонів державних з
регіональних службам це як в мене вже є
величезними досягненням самим по собі і
якби не став всім хто дійсно долучився
до цієї роботи під обстрілами під час
відключень світла
як на мене це вже саме по собі величезна
досягнення говорить прості якісь системи
і великі можливості другий такий блок
результатів Я знову ж таки не буду
вдаватись в деталі але насправді
якщо відкинути умовно відкинути ті
[музика]
величезні економічні виклики які
поставили через агресію Російської
Федерації І
зменшення виробництва і знищення
підприємств міграція величезна це все
очевидно було тлом цього дослідження але
Попри це трембі які ми спостерігали і до
війни тобто тенденція до того що
запит на професії які ми умовно
називаємо вед професії тобто професії
які в основному навчаються чи
генеруються системи професійної освіти
цей зростає і вона тільки збільшила цей
попит
Ми так само бачимо подальше зростання
тренду на те що ми називаємо умовно Soft
Skills тобто наскрізні навички
це робота в команді це
стресу стійкість очевидно під час війни
дуже важлива навички це знання іноземних
мов і так далі ми зробили детальний
аналіз по галузянку до цих навичок і за
бажанням можемо його надати так само ми
бачимо в цілому
зростання бажання підприємств навіть на
те що зростання але попри війну ми
бачимо те що тренер до того щоб
підприємства хочуть вчити своїх
працівників бачать в цьому потребу бачу
хочуть інвестувати це
щоб теж дуже
надихає особливо під час війни цей тренд
залишився і я думаю що він буде зростати
Тобто ми далі говоримо про потребу в
більш гнучких короткотермінових
навчальних програмах які
навчальні заклади чи провайдери навчання
повинні розробляти Тобто це такі є Я
розумію що вже п'ятниця вечір тому я не
буду дуже багато вдавати деталі але це
такі кілька основних глобальних
висновків про які можна говорити за
результатами цього Дослідження які як на
мене пройти треба дуже добре думати
системі освіти яким чином інтегрувати і
Міккі на вички яким чином змінювати
формат гнучкість програм для того щоб
забезпечити потреби ринку праці і під
час він вже після відбудови Дякую колеги
не буду завантажувати більше ефір
більшою кількістю інформації я буду
вдячний за ваші питання коментарі
задоволенням відповім
пане генна дуже дякуємо за вашу дуже
коротку але як кажуть англійською дуже
таку багато інформативно презентацію
Хоча вона і зроблена була тільки
аудіально я думав у нас буде можливість
На жаль ми вже вичерпали практично час У
нас є тільки ще два коменти я зараз
скажу від когось залу умовно кажучи і ми
обов'язково опублікуємо
українсько-англійську всі матеріали які
сьогодні застосовані були всі
презентації більше того Якщо пан
Геннадій дозволить то ми зможемо надати
посилання на те дослідження про яке ви
говорите
можна було з цим ознайомитись ви знаєте
що наша подія відбувається в межах
всеукраїнського тижня професійних
навичок відповідно на сайті minusvita
обов'язково будуть опубліковані
матеріали кожної події і ми їх
розповсюдимо А зараз у нас немає вже
багато часу для дискусій але все ж таки
двом людям ми обов'язково дамо слово
спершу нашій колезі з Естонії аномальна
річ яка працює в дуже цікавому проекті
який займається програмами тренінгів для
підвищення експортної спроможності малих
і середніх підприємств це дуже пов'язано
з іншими
проблемами Перед якими ми стоїмо ми не
дивлячись на війну все одно Україна
готується вступити до приєднатися до
Європейського Союзу і тому питання
інтернаціоналізації економіки і всіх
видів бізнесу дуже є важливим нам було б
цікаво почути про ці тренінги які
готують наші колеги в Естонії разом з
експорт промоушена офіс прийняли
економіки а також можливо почути щось
про ті навички які є важливими саме для
інтернаціоналізації бізнесу слово вам
Паніна річ
вітаю вас
Я радий сьогодні приєднатися я нова на
цьому поприщі назвати Ганна Я з Естонії
яке писала в чаті ми запускаємо три
програми по Україні цього місяця
ми працюємо у вас вже років 5 ще було до
війни
У нас є
5000 компаній які беруть участь нашої
програми це велика група випускників які
я по Україні я хочу відзначити два
моменти перша стосується методики як
зрозуміти потребу
ми дізналися про те що важливо завжди
говорити з випускниками своїми про те що
відбулося Після навчання Коли вони вже
його завершили
І це допомагає нам краще дізнатися про
те як навчати певних навичок тих хто
навчається
і ми це досвід узагальнюємо ми розуміємо
що буде далі Чи отримав навички Чи ви
можете їх використовувати Чи ви можете
їх використовувати на вашому
підприємстві Чи ви можете здобути змін
зростити експорт отаке питання йому
завжди ставимо перед випускниками і
презентатор розуміємо які навички які ми
можемо додали зі свого боку але вони
потрібні які навички люди отримали тим
не менш не змогли використати
що Це дало от все це включено в цикл
підготовки та розробки наших програм
коли ви не розпочалася в нас була чотири
програми по Україні
ми їх припинили спочатку пережили
потрясіння
але не кинули підприємствами зрозуміли
що до чого і
послухали кампанію побачили які освітні
потреби в них є
Коли вже люди були готові Приступити до
навчання знову І ми дізналися також про
те що у багатьох наших програмах
ми передбачаємо колективне взаємодію і
Якщо говорити про програми яка
стосується
відновлення і організація які втом буде
задіяні то є там ціла складова про те як
різні компанії можна вивести на рівень
взаємодії для того щоб зрозуміти як один
одному довіряти
це важливо тому що ми дивилися на це з
Європейського боку і більшість
підприємств буде шукати партнерів по
Україні і важливо щоб ви знаходили тих
партнерів з якими можна працювати разом
А щодо навичок то ми також розуміємо
особливо коли розпочалася війна
ми
пробуло зводити українське та закордонні
кампанії потрібно мати навички
встановлення таких заявлень і різні
культури різних підходи І в вас є в
Європі
Ми також розуміємо що багато комунікацій
та маркетингу допомагає вам завжди так
щоб вас побачили і почули і
застосуванням цифрових технологій диких
галузах цифровізацією покращує в деяких
погірше вже йде Це про те щоб цифрові
навички були в людей що вони просто
змогли зв'язатися один з одним
Також ми розуміємо що коли працюєш з
малими та середніми підприємствами то
зміна розпочинається зверху слід робити
просвітницьку роботу серед керівників
керівного складу якщо ви не бачать
потреби зміни хто тоді вони Власне цей
здійснюють
я хотіла присвятити всі секретаря та
всіх фахівців в компаніях але на жаль
вони не прагне змін вони
роблять те що погодили керівництво Тому
ми маємо працювати з керівництвом
про це ми дізналися почули і на це
робимо нахил своїх програмах а в плані
відновлення ми визначили що це будуть
будівник компанії інженерні компанії
архітектурні бюро
цифрові компанії потрібні
консультативні фірми які будуть
допомагати європейським компаніям там
окопатись на території країни після
війни Тому це такі сектори з якими ми
працюємо сьогодні і це основна програма
в нас більше ніж 300 учасників і
ми будемо готувати
допомагати їм набувати навичок протягом
року є дві інші програми з якими ми
працюємо це експертна консультанти ми
два роки це робимо
і здобули певний досвід є успішний
приклад того як можна формувати
варіанти бізнес-консультації
ми маленька країна Естонія Ми не можемо
дати просвіту всім українським малим та
середнім підприємствам по експорту
потрібні консультанти та фахівці на
території України які це робили ми їх
маємо підготувати а вони вже з
урахування місцевої специфіки може це
донести до інших
є експерти по
експорту так і вони можуть
проконсультувати підприємство щоб ті
змогли вижити і потім розвиватись далі І
вони мають володіти різними навичками що
про замітий різні економічні галузі
шифони були тільки консультанти в одній
галузято помагали підприємствам деяких
глазах є ще й додаткові новачки які ми
даємо стосовно
командних взаємодії лідерства
комунікації Але це вже додатково
англійська мова вона є в наших усіх
програмах також можна підтягнути
англійську в нас також ну і
і експерта трендери які мають відповідно
досвід по експорту і можуть підтримати
компанію В цьому плані
на цими працюємо і вже в червні ми
будемо набирати нові учасників нашої
програми
Дякуємо вам і в чаті вже проводиться
одна інформація за Олександрою Вона дала
там посилання на певні знаряддя яке було
спільно створені мопс і ситіфом
ще одна представниця Федерація
роботодавців України пані Людмила
василега вона б надала також вчатьбоксі
дуже цікаві посилання на у тому числі на
сайт де опубліковане
дослідження ринку праці на якому про яке
нам розповідав пан Геннадій тому у кого
є час дивіться будь ласка що у нас в чат
боксі відбувається пані василего вам
пару слів Що ви хотіли сказати Як
коменти до сьогоднішньої зустрічі І
потім заключне слово належитиме ще й
пані але сандрі мольц дуже дякую за
надане слово Вітаю усіх Дякую за дуже
цікаво вебінар корисними Я сподіваюсь на
те що ми зможемо надалі продовжити
роботу дійсно у чаті Я надала посилання
близькі Дослідження які ми робили в
минулому році і в цьому році щодо
опитування роботодавців в цілому
прогнозуванні ринку праці і так там
також там є правда українською тільки
мовою дослідження форсайд України 4:0 це
прогнозування цифрових навичок в
сільському господарстві тому дуже багато
цікавого хто ще не бачив не отримував цю
інформацію коли у нас були презентації
будь ласка ви можете скопіювати зайти
подивитися на сайті Я хотіла б дуже
коротко дійсно прокоментувати Тому що це
цікаво потребує ще подальших зустрічей
але те що пан Геннадій казав що
підприємство побачило по опитуванню
навчають навчали навчають і будуть
навчати і навіть нові тенденції у нас
з'явилися зараз багато компаній
перенавчають жінок на чоловічі професії
Ну враховуючи ту ситуацію яка зараз є у
багатьох компаніях і такі приклади У нас
є зокрема в агру і також хотіли би ще
буквально декілька акцентів це перше що
коли прогнозують навички нам потрібно
звертати увагу на Soft Skills тому що ця
тенденція зростає і у нас є порівняння
навіть під час війни у вакансіях
роботодавці більше зазначали потребу у
совскілс навіть чим це було до війни
тому розвиток софський ліфт - це така
болюча тема тому що роботодавця
потребують А ця тема поки дещо вискорзає
з розвитку попередньо перед тим як
працівник працевлаштовується і другим
важливий акцент - Це в тому що нам
потрібно загальні дослідження більш
розкладати на регіональні дані тому що
регіональне замовлення та бюджет
підготовки професійний він у регіоні А
коли ми бачимо досить загальні дані
опитування прогнозування не розкладаючи
на території там потім їм важко взяти цю
потребу з результатів для Влас таких як
потім планувати і готувати власне в
регіоні тому такий акцент для того щоб
загальні дослідження мали і досить-таки
потужну регіональний компонент Ну і
головний як це в тому щоб якщо ми беремо
методику дуже важливо ті напрацювання
досвід на організації праці то Така
пропозиція щоб ми це системно впроваджує
декілька років тому що роботодавців
єдине питання що ми відповідаємо і
досить активно беремо участь у
фокус-групах і фокус групи дуже такі
гарний якісний метод опитування і він
надає інколи більше інформації ніж
просто опитування роботодавця але потім
з результатом Нічого не відбувається і
наша потреба не ми не бачимо в
реалізації певних програм
перенавчання розвитку або в державних
політиках тому ми за ми готові бути
активно рушійною силою Дякуємо за
опитування що роботодавців повинні це
робити Ми згодні і У багатьох країнах
саме
асоціації об'єднані роботодавцем цим
займається але головне щоб ми системно
працювали над цим питанням і потім ці
результати були враховані при подальших
діях та політиках Дякуємо Дуже дякую
пані Людмила Велике вам спасибі як за
вашу участь в кінці робочого дня навіть
вже коза ним у п'ятницю так і за ваші
дуже конкретні пропозиції для освітян
вони є дуже важливими зрозуміло що
тільки освітяни роботодавці ті хто
займається питаннями взагалі соціального
розвитку тільки всі разом ми можемо
досягати реальних змін у зайнятості у
розвитку людського капіталу я можу
тільки висловити велику вдячність І всім
учасникам всім спікерам всім хто
допомагав нам зробити цю подію можливою
і під кінець хочу надати слово
представниці головного організатора
власне сьогоднішньої події міжнародної
організації праці саме пані Олександрі
мольц
iона
я не буду вас затримувати хочу
подякувати всім за те що були з нами
Міністерство освіти
платформі і тим хто співпрацює з нами я
хочу подякувати всім учасникам
за активне залучення що ми бачили і в
чаті і виступах в ефірі це демонструє
нам те що це тема є актуальною і все в
тому зацікавлені їх бажають продовження
співпраці
набуття навичок це актуальна тема і все
можна знайти на веб-сайті там Тетяна
розташовувала посилання на нього в чаті
Я думаю там цей матеріал ви зможете
відповідні знайти тож вам дякую і бажаю
вам мирних вихідних до побачення
до побачення
Героям слава Героям слава
Разом до перемоги